est-ce que ça se peut de naître sans
cerveau je sais à quoi vous pensez mais
c'est pas ça pas du tout naître son
cerveau ça s'appelle être ah non c'est
fan
là dans céphalie C'est quand on n'a pas
d'hémisphère cérébraux ça c'est les deux
grosses masses là qui sont collées qu'on
appelle le cerveau même si en vrai il y
a d'autres trucs qui en font partie mais
comme on les voit moins on en parle
moins cette malformation elle arrive
parce que pendant la grossesse pour des
raisons qu'on s'explique pas encore
complètement il y a un truc qui
s'appelle le tube neural qui se referme
pas correctement dans le cas de
l'annoncéphalie en plus du cerveau il
manque aussi de la boîte crânienne les
os du crâne si vous voulez ils s'arrête
en général juste au dessus des sourcils
donc les bébés annoncéphales ont une
apparence très significative et oui je
parle de bébé seulement parce que ceux
qui en sont atteints ne survivent pas
plus de quelques heures voire quelques
jours à l'exception notable du petit
Jackson Buell qui est né avec une
annoncéphalie partielle et qui a survécu
jusqu'à ses 5 ans voilà donc comme je
vous l'ai dit là non c'est Fally c'est
une maladie rare et on sait pas
exactement quel en est